ايضا بالكاميرا الى الجهه المقابله لاسرد
لك قصه اخرى نتابعها ولكن من بعيد لانها
يعني هنالك حساسيه وخوف كبير من البنايه
التي تجاهدينها الان عبر الكاميرا هذه
البنايه ميسون لم تنهار ولكنها سقطت في
الاسفل
بعمق التسويه وهنالك ثلاث شباب سوريين
محاصرين داخل تسويه هذه البنايه كان احد
اقربائهم اتصل معهم واجاب احد الاشخاص تحت
الانقاض على الهاتف واكد انه على قيد
الحياه وهذا كان امس الاتصال بعد ذلك
الهاتف يرن ولا يجيبوا وجاء فريق متخصص
اليوم ولديه اجهزه متطوره واكد ان هنالك
حياه لاشخاص تحت الانقاض ويعني من خلال
الاجهزه تبين ان هنالك من هو على قيد
الحياه وبالتالي عمليات حساسه جدا ان كانت
زميل يستطيع الدخول اكثر في الكاميرا الى
هناك هم يقول اي اص يعني بالنسبه لرجال
الانقاذ ان يحاولوا ان يشيلوا الركام
ليجدوا من تحته او انه ببنايه مثل هذه او
هذا المبنى ان يحاول الوصول الى القاع
وخاصه انه ممكن فكره انهيار المبنى نفسه
تكون قائمه صحيح بالضبط بالضبط يعني انا
اكثر عمليه انقاذ اراها حساسه هذه العمليه
رغم ان البنايه غير منهاره لانهم حذروا
احنا كنا اقتربنا للتصوير هناك وكان تحذير
حازم جدا انه لن يقف هناك سوى فرق الانقاذ
لانه في بعض رجال الانقاذ دخلوا بالفعل
على عمق امتار في تلك البنايه الان هم تحت
يحاولوا ان يدخلوا ويصلوا الى هؤلاء
الاشخاص العالقين وتحدثت من قبل بانه قصه
هؤلاء الشباب احدهم جاء من اسطنبول الى
هذه المدينه ليله الزلزال ميسون يعني
تمهيدا لكتب كتابه للزواج ولكنه للاسف
يعني هذا كان ما حدث معه انه تحت الانقاذ